j'ai cinq enfants
j'ai une fille aussi que l'infirmière je
monte en première ligne donc jusqu'à ce
que le canard sauce il incline d'image
c'est derrière ces lettres que se trouve
peut-être la formule magique pour que le
virus ne soit plus qu'un mauvais
souvenir
en tout cas yvon hurtubise y croit dur
comme fer
ulysse biotechnologies n'a aucune
expérience des vaccins en fait ici à
trois-rivières on élabore des produits
de type bactérien qui ont pour objectif
de favoriser la croissance des plantes
si c'est la première étape de sélection
des souches un domaine qui peut être en
fait très utile quand vient le temps de
trouver un vaccin liver tubize a donc
synthétiser un fragment de la séquence
du virus et veulent introduire dans une
bactérie ou une levure
donc c'est comme une clé qui rentrent
navarrenx et rond il travaille donc sur
la conception d'une levure qui aurait
les mêmes propriétés que le virus mais
sans la charge contagieuse de lakovic 19
et qui déclencherait dans l'organisme de
celui qui prend ce vaccin par voie orale
ou spray nasal une réaction
d'immunisation
c'est la technique du leur ont fait
croire à l'organisme humain qui est
attaquée mais il est pauvre on a juste
besoin d'avoir un contact qui vous sera
de façon intime avec une protéine très
spécifique au niveau des cellules
humaines et de cette façon là les encore
ce qu'on souhaite vont commencer à être
produite au fur et à mesure mais pour y
arriver il faut d'abord trouver la bonne
formule
une de ces formules potentiel medicago
une compagnie québécoise déjà bien
positionné dans le domaine des vaccins
pense l'avoir trouvé grâce aux plantes
des plantes capables de faire des choses
extrêmement complexe alors produire des
particules pseudo virales c'est pas
toutes les technologies qui sont
capables de faire la plante est capable
de faire des plans c'est facile à faire
croire c'est ce qu'on fait dans nos
serres technologie fait en sorte qu'on
produit très rapidement on a produit un
vaccin
c'est un vaccin qu'on est présentement
en train d'étudier shelly modèles
animaux et on prévoit commencer les
études cliniques cet été pour la plupart
c'est surtout les petites compagnies qui
sont en avant selon brian ward sur la
centaine de compagnies dans le monde qui
travaillent sur un vaccin et ce peu
importe la méthode choisie pour le
développement celles qui vont réussir
devront s'unir pour desservir la planète
il n'y a aucune compagnie à ce moment
qui peut produire vaccins suffisant pour
toutes les personnes du monde
en attendant de son côté pour justement
produire un nombre astronomique de doses
qu'ils espèrent prochainement efficace
contre le virus
ils hurtubise utilisent des fermenteurs
comme celui ci dans le fermenteur qu'est
ce qu'on vous retrouver vous avez
simplement un milieu nutritionnelle qui
va favoriser la croissance des bactéries
tout ça pour arriver à la production de
cette sphère qui pourrait mener à
l'immunisation contre le virus
la première étape on va voir ça va être
le contrôle qualité la stabilisation
font donc s'assurer qu'ils ont une
culture qui l'espace faire son come on
les bactéries et probiotiques matthieu
millet tu connais et a décidé de se
joindre au projet puisque dans cette
course
l'union fait la force il travaille chez
bio k + qui produit des million de
gélules et yo gourd pour équilibrer la
flore intestinale
il pense que son secteur toute sa place
dans cette course au vaccin utilisé des
bactéries vivantes comme vecteur de
vaccins c'est une idée qui date de dire
une vingtaine d'années donc c'est de
plus en plus étudiée il ya beaucoup de
ce type de vaccin qui est utilisé dans
l'industrie animal chez l'humain à ma
connaissance n'est pas encore deux
précédents donc c'est vraiment très
innovateur c'est avec la compagnie
canadienne l'allemand un géant des
levures et bactéries qu'il espère aller
le plus loin possible
l'objectif numéro 1 avec l'allemand avec
mu les biotechnologies bcc réellement de
faire une preuve de concept jusqu'au
modèle animal
et puis après ça va faire trouver un
partenaire pharmaceutique qui a les
reins solides pour conduire les études
cliniques
parce que des études cliniques ça coûte
cher ça prend du temps et d'autres
compétences
mais pour l'instant y virent tubize est
plutôt serein oui à des très grandes
entreprises au niveau ferme là qui vont
faire des choses vraiment énorme avec
des moyens financiers finma incroyable
désir à ce niveau le mot sentais pas
comme j'ai pas besoin d'avoir
millions pour avancer ils m'ont regardé
s'il faut pas pousser plus vite les
nombreuses initiatives prometteuses
comme celle là pourrait accélérer le
rythme d'approbation des futurs vaccins
par les autorités médicales
si les données des des essais cliniques
initiales sont vraiment prometteur je
pense que on peut voir un avance vers
distribution plus est large et beaucoup
plus vite que 18 mois mais c'est une
balance entre la sécurité et
l'efficacité
et si jamais les tests ne sont pas
concluants alors yves hurtubise ne
baissera pas les bras
quand 29 va changer a commencé à changer
et il ya d'autres virus qui vont venir
dans le système qu'on propose un système
qui va toujours être maudit l'âme les
essais erreurs vont donc se poursuivre
dans cette course au vaccin qui sera
peut-être pour lui et pour d'autres une
course relais pour sauver des vies
m